notre tandem du vendredi madeleine et
sébastien bonsoir à vous soit avec toi
alors mais on va parler dans quelques
instants de la fin des travaux
parlementaires entre des activités
parlementaires aujourd'hui tant tawaqa
québec mais revenons sur la commune 19
le portrait sanitaires aux pays qui
posent très glorieux si on veut les
choses s'enveniment son nouveau cent
mille nouveaux cas l'échelle nationale
au cours des trois dernières semaines
des projections d'un copé qui n'augure
rien de bon
d une période risquée en vue nous dit
ottawa madeleine oui effectivement alors
on a eu le portrait encore une fois
aujourd'hui de la santé publique
est ce qu'on nous dit c'est que si on
maintient les niveaux de contacts
actuels
on devrait avoir environ 12000 qu'à
chaque jour au mois de janvier donc
c'est à peu près le double du nombre de
cas au quotidien en ce moment entre
autres parce que l'école continue
d'augmenter rapidement dans les
provinces de l'ouest du pays alors ce
que dit justin trudeau aujourd'hui en
point de presse c'est que c'est le temps
de ralentir maintenant ou de diminuer
maintenant le niveau de contact et je
voudrais que le message aussi que la
santé publique a passé c'est que oui on
a eu des bonnes nouvelles récemment
oui on la voit la lumière au bout du
tunnel avec le vaccin mais que le vaccin
qu'on n'a pas encore ça change rien dans
la pandémie actuelle ça change rien dans
le niveau de la courbe alors faut pas
avoir un faux sentiment de sécurité
avec ce vaccin qui s'en vient les
contacts actuels continuent en ce moment
de propager la pandémie donc il faut
essayer de changer les comportements
c'est ça c'était une semaine assez
particulière où il a fallu vrai sur deux
francs le vaccin signe d'espoir s'il en
est un mais en même temps cette prudence
qui doit être de mise à tous les
instants de nos vies finalement
sébastien oui puis avec un rappel des
consignes sanitaires c'est pas parce que
le vaccin est qu'il faut baisser la
garde
on a utilisé une analogie de guerre le
sait pas parce que la guerre tire à sa
fin que on veut revenir blessé de la
guerre donc
ouverte en du québec le message a
toujours été de respecter les consignes
sanitaires
on songe à resserrer ses consignes là
parce que on s'aperçoit que la
progression de maladies continuent
malgré les appels l'espèce de persuasion
qu'on essaie de faire convaincre les
québécois d'appliquer les mesures
sénégal alors mais les détails ou lady
avait donné tout à l'heure sébastien de
ses possibles restrictions à venir qu'en
début de semaine lundi ou mardi ça reste
à voir
le coeur du problème c'est encore et
toujours les les pressions sur le
système de santé
oui avec le nombre d'hospitalisations
augmente on est presque à 900 alors dans
la réflexion de françois legault c'est à
contre-coeur que il va probablement
imposer de nouvelles restrictions parce
que il se dit dans la réflexion donc on
veut pas pénaliser la majorité qui
respectent les consignes sanitaires à
cause d'une minorité de personnes qui ne
les respectent pas pu noter que cette
semaine le message qu'il a commencé par
envoyer ses les policiers seront plus
sévères on va vous donner des amendes
d'ailleurs on apprend aujourd'hui qu'à
la baie au saguenay il ya un monsieur
qui a reçu une amende de 1500 46 dollar
parce qu'il est allé visiter couple
c'est interdit vous n'avez pas le droit
d'aller visiter un côté elle pouvait
aller visiter une personne seule vous
pouvez pas seul à les visiter un couple
eur ça envoie comme le message que roux
c'est finalement les policiers
appliquent en effet la réglementation à
la lettre du moins les policiers de
saguenay est donc cette étape là étant
franchie mais le nombre de cas augmente
en quelle est la prochaine étape c'est
probablement un resserrement des mesures
probablement pendant la période des
fêtes parce qu'on s'aperçoit qu'il ya un
ralentissement de l'économie donc c'est
plus propice au fait que les gens en
fait les gens restent plus à la maison
donc c'est peut-être plus propice à un
resserrement des mesures et c'est tout
ça donc qui va rentrer en ligne de
compte dans la réflexion du premier
bidamant tard on se garde bien
d'encourager les provinces à faire quoi
que ce soit ce soit au sens du nord et
du nord-est d'un resserrement ou non des
mesures sanitaires
en fait ce que le gouvernement trudeau
et c'est de dire depuis des semaines
déjà c'est que si les provinces veulent
agir
le gouvernement fédéral va aider les
entreprises sera là pour essayer
d'amener de dédommager les entreprises
qui doivent fermer notamment en raison
de mesures plus strictes imposées par
les provinces
donc est ce que le gouvernement à cette
dire c'est ne vous empêche les potagers
au nom de l'économie où seront là nous
gouvernement fédéral pour vous aider et
ça me ramène à la rencontre d'hier la
rencontre fédérale-provinciale là dessus
justin trudeau a toujours été très très
très clair il va être généreux pour ce
qui est des mesures très urgente de
pandémie pour ce qui est de la suite par
contre la hausse des transferts en santé
réclamé par les provinces on est prêt à
dire oui faut augmenter les transferts
mais on peut pas s'engager sur des
mesures précises sur un chèque sur une
date sûre sur des montants là dessus il
va falloir attendre donc on est sur deux
plans ce qui est urgent oui on va aider
le la presse va falloir encore négocier
sébastien batut sur les lignes justement
les transferts en santé les demandes des
provinces seront elles patientent seront
en route et la sagesse d'être patiente
oui c'est une excellente question sur le
front commun des provinces on avait
l'impression hier je peux subjectif
comment que justin trudeau et françois
legault avait pas assisté à la même
conférence soit la même réunion parce
que justin trudeau disais je suis ouvert
à mater les transferts fédéraux mais pas
tout de suite françois legault 10 est un
rendez vous manqué il s'est pas engagé à
augmenter les transferts fédéraux
on est dans la nuance ce que les
provinces veulent et en particulier
françois legault c'est de l'argent
sonnant chèque qu'il peut lui dépensé
dans ses soins de santé sans se faire
dire comment il doit dépenser cet argent
justin trudeau lui veut peut-être un peu
diriger l'argent ce disant oui on peut
peut-être être au rendez vous mais à
certaines conditions donc on est un peu
en décalage peut être qu'on va finir par
s'entendre
mais françois legault mise beaucoup sur
le front commun des premiers ministres
les autres ministres qui sont avec lui
pour faire pression sur le gouvernement
fédéral
à cet égard à cet égard un peu
d'histoire en 2016 2017
il y avait aussi un front commun des
premiers ministres des provinces et les
prières qui était au pouvoir au québec
c'est quand john wayne qui étaient là en
ontario 48,1 moins de 48 heures après
cette fameuse réunion première réunion
ont pris des contacts pour faire
pression sur le gouvernement fédéral
brian gallant du nouveau brunswick
accepter un deal une enceinte du
gouvernement fédéral et donc briser la
chaîne de solidarité
puis un an plus tard il restait juste
france le québec l'ontario le manitoba
et l'alberta
finalement tout le monde a signé une
entente bilatérale avec ottawa parce que
c'est ce qui va se produire dans ce
front commun
de 2020 2021 on ne sait pas mais disons
que l'histoire nous apprend que des fois
chacun payé pour son propriétaire
c'est peut-être dans les calculs
d'ottawa madeleine sa commande et rend
diviser pour mieux régner ça serait
peut-être l'expression qui
s'appliquerait dans ce cas ci mais là je
vous dirais qu'on est même pas sûr du
moment où on va vouloir négocier
donc on n'est même pas essayé de briser
le fonds table on dit ou province
on n'a pas le portrait en ce moment 2 du
système de santé post pandémique donc il
va falloir essayer d'évaluer
véritablement les besoins
donc ce que le gouvernement fédéral a
fait hier si il a dit oui un sébastien à
la question d'avoir une augmentation des
transferts mais faites moi confiance et
ça viendra plus tard donc le camp le
cormier et le comment cette augmentation
tous tous les détails restent à
déterminer et beaucoup de détails qui
restent à déterminer et parlant de
détail qui restait à déterminer on
n'avait toujours pas eu les chiffres en
ce qui concerne l'albertain aujourd'hui
l'augmentation des cas on vient de me
souffler à l'oreille mais 738 quand
additionnel pour l'alberta 18 décès qui
s'ajoute malheureusement et au tableau
c'est le ratio s'est autant qu'elle
québec avec deux fois moins une pop il
exactement d'où la gravité de la
situation en alberta l'alberta qui avait
été présenté peut-être de façon un peu
caricaturale mais ça allait dans la même
tendance que comme la suède du canada
avec une approche beaucoup plus laxiste
et madeleine oui effectivement rien en
ce moment on voit les limites de cette
stratégie qu'avait adopté jason kenny
qui lui craignait justement les impacts
des mesures trop restrictives sur
l'économie et probablement aussi
craignent les impacts d'une population
qui était elle même un peu sceptique par
rapport à certaines mesures de santé
publique donc là et il a essayé
d'accommoder tout le monde est il
finalement ça fait plaisir à personne
c'est ça qui a été compliqué pour lui
parce qu'on a vu son taux d'approbation
ben c'est sensiblement au cours des
dernières semaines donc il essaie de se
rattraper maintenant mais ce que la
santé publique fédérale avait dit c'est
qu'il vaut mieux agir tant que la
pandémie et c'est une image qu'on vous
avait présenté il ya quelques semaines
c'est un peu comme une montagne russe
mais à l'envers
au lieu de deux
descendre rapidement et de monter
lentement c'est le contraire alors les
corps peuvent remonter extrêmement
rapidement s'enflammer et que c'est
difficile par la suite de rabaisser la
courbe
quand la contamination et eau en milieu
communautaire c'est plus difficile à
contrôler et dans l'alberta où on est
très jaloux des libertés individuelles
peut-être des choses qui étaient plus
difficiles à mettre en place dans
l'esprit de monsieur kenny il faut
absolument qu'on parle du plan
climatique du fédéral présenté
aujourd'hui on l'évoqué tout à l'heure
avec monsieur guilbeault somme toute
madeleine a si bien accueilli par les
milieux environnementalistes montant
dont on a entendu la grogne très très
apparente de monsieur ford en ontario en
ce qui concerne la tarification sur le
carbone qui est conséquent et les il
était contre cette taxe sur le carbone
là qui dit pas monsieur ford par contre
c'est que l'argent est perçue par la
taxe est remise dans les portefeuilles
des canadiens et là aussi on n'a pas
beaucoup parlé dans l'émission jusqu'ici
c'est qu'il ya une stratégie politique
aussi au lieu de camoufleurs camoufler
parce que le gouvernement jamais voulu
camoufler mais au lieu d'un ce rsa dans
leur retour d'impôts 7 ce retour
d'argent là les canadiens qui sont
soumis à la taxe sur le carbone vont
recevoir trois chèques par année dont
rappel trois fois par année voici
l'argent qui vous est remis pour la taxe
sur le carbone qui est perçu à la pompe
notamment
donc si stratégiquement probablement
plus payant la part du gouvernement
prudent de procéder de la sorte et c'est
peut-être pas une mauvaise idée parce
que la taxe sur le carbone va augmenter
considérablement avec une augmentation
de 15 $ par année à partir de 2022 pour
atteindre 170 dollars la tonne en 2030
donc c'est le gros de la stratégie pour
lutter contre les champs pour les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre pour
essayer de les réduire et de miser sur
la taxe sur la carte
le gros de la stratégie fédérale reste
aux provinces ou si maintenant sébastien
à définir un peu la leur stratégie
respective
oui pis si on a au québec on à la bourse
du carbone mais qui
un peu fragilisé parce qu'il ya juste le
québec la californie qui sont à la gorge
du carbone monsieur ford de l'ontario
s'en est retirée donc pour acheter et
vendre des droits de polluer donc ici au
québec le plan vert du gouvernement
étaient présentés étaient quand même
relativement bien à qui est reçu même si
on ne franchit que 40 % de l'objectif
avec des mesures annoncées par le
gouvernement du québec moi ce qui
m'étonne au point de vue fédéral
mais c'est sur la forme seulement c'est
que c'est steven guilbeault qui vient
votre émission donner des entrevues
c'est le ministre du patrimoine après
tout c'est pas le ministre de
l'environnement au fédéral mais on
comprend qu'il devient une espèce de
caution verte caution
environnementalistes environnementale
pour justement vous avez raison mais il
ne devient pas une caution il est encore
une caution c'est ça les gens sont
ensemble se sont peut-être poser la
question pourquoi monsieur le ministre
du patrimoine parle de ce dossier mais
madeleine il continue à voir si on veut
une présence dans les cercles
décisionnels en ce qui concerne les
dossiers environnementaux ottawa
monsieur qu'il bombe a déjà dit qu'il
faisait du travail parascolaires il a
son travail de ministre du patrimoine
canadien et il continue de s'intéresser
à toute la question des changements
climatiques et avec madame mécano la
ministre de l'industrie et avec monsieur
wilkinson le ministre de l'environnement
et se sont rassemblés en outre pendant
la pandémie pour essayer de trouver des
façons justement de contribuer à la
reprise économique après la pandémie
avec des mesures et des mesures version
vos dons qu'ils ont essayé de faire du
travail à penser après la pandémie eux
étaient moins impliqués dans la gestion
très très urgent de la pandémie dont
qu'ils étaient plutôt dans le après que
monsieur guy bon ce n'est pas officiel
mais c'était vraiment public le clip
faisait partie de ce petit groupe avec
un jeu après la pandémie et peut-être
aussi une éventuelle élection fédérale
bien entendu par l'ondé bilan de session
maintenant québec et ottawa commençons
par québec sébastien aujourd'hui je suis
le goût qui s'est bien gardé de se
donner notre parfaite pour ce qui est de
la gestion de la pandémie
mais moi je remarque une certaine quand
même dans le ton à l'assemblée nationale
c'était plus cordiales
c'était plus cordiales mais c'est pas
nécessairement symptomatique de la façon
dont les choses se sont déroulées
pendant sa session parlementaire parce
que oui aujourd'hui dominique anglade a
donné des cadeaux à chacun des chefs à
l'assemblée nationale
tout le monde avait de boom bons mots
pour la gestion de la crise pour la
façon dont les oppositions sont
comportés mais des fois c'est étendu et
monsieur le groupe parfois je posterai
semaine dernière un peu perdu son calme
à l'assemblée nationale et d'une
certaine façon compréhensible il doit
être très fatigué ça fait neuf mois
qu'ils gèrent cette pandémie et cette
session aussi les partis d'opposition un
peu trouvé de lumière je vous dis restez
très difficile au printemps de trouver
de la lumière pour les classes de
position tout le monde était dans
l'effort de guerre
là on se pose plus de questions sur la
gestion du gouvernement
il leur rapport d'étape la protectrice
du citoyen qui critiquent la façon dont
le siège c'est-à-dire ont été gérés il
ya beaucoup de caisses de questionnement
sur la façon dont les décisions sont
prises dans la cellule de crise
personne n'y est dans l'opposition dans
cette cellule de crise on sait pas
vraiment comment ça fonctionne mais on
sent une fatigue aussi des gens donc qui
soulève certaines critiques à l'égard du
gouvernement donc les partis
d'opposition a peut-être eu un peu plus
de lumière cette session aussi pour se
faire valoir
même si c'était mono sujet même si on ne
parlait que d'accorder encore et
toujours
même dynamique en tahoua madeleine et eu
aussi beaucoup de critiques quant à part
de l'opposition officielle alors à
l'endroit de justin trudeau notamment
dans toute la période assez récente
quand même où on s'attendait à recevoir
les vaccins quand même quelques semaines
plus tard que d'autres pays comme les
etats-unis comme la grande-bretagne et
la justin trudeau est arrivé en fin de
session en dix ans vont non seulement
nous allons avoir des doses très
rapidement donc dès la semaine prochaine
mais en plus on a approuvé ce vaccin là
avant les états unis
donc ça un petit peu finalement redorer
la fin de session du gouvernement
trudeau
mais une cession qui est quand même
assez bien été pour lui rappeler vous là
au début de la session se demander si
toute la sphère unis nous sommes loin
mais appelez vous que le gouvernement
avait prorogé la session probablement un
peu pour cela pour essayer de deux dents
de retirer sa des écrans radar et il est
parvenu à le faire donc ça a été un pari
réussi pour lui il ya eu des petits
éléments qui
plus compliquées entre autres la
question de la langue française donc des
dommages auto infligée je vous dirais
avec les commentaires de dhabi la député
d'arrière-ban emmanuel à l'amour au
boulot ça c'est une période un peu plus
compliqué mais somme toute une session
quand même assez assez efficace pour le
gouvernement
juste avant qu'on poursuive sur ce qui
assurerait la semaine prochaine ne faut
pas faux faut rappeler quand même
qu'ottawa demandeuses troisième report
d'un dossier de l'aide médicale à mourir
à la juge baudouin au 26 février c'est
ce que demande ottawa le ministre de la
justice david la métier a fait la
demande en disant qu'il espère qu'il
n'aura pas besoin de l'avoir cette
période de prolongation là j'espère que
d'ici le 18 décembre c'est la date d'un
cake était prévu là pour la laddh la
dernière extension ou le dernier délai
mais il reste toute l'étape à passer au
sénat
et moi j'ai bien l'impression que en une
semaine ils réussirent pas à faire
adopter sa loi
mais le souffle par les projets de
prorogation le position officielle dit
peut-être que c'est le gouvernement
n'avait pas proroger les travaux ont
duré huit ans de la passé alors en
quelques mots sébastien madeleine la
semaine prochaine d'ici à noël
finalement qu'est-ce qui a surveillé les
premiers québécois seront vaccinés le
dit et rosberg ont fait son annonce
lundi à mardi sur ds wii
madeleine vaccin vaccin vaccin on va
regarder comment s'est déroulée cette
opération est exactement et monsieur
legault qui va être grande réflexion ce
week end avec son équipe merci à vous
bon week-end au revoir au revoir pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit